they are marginalized discriminated
against and persecuted the Hazara people
originally native to the mountains of
central afghanistan Hazaras also make up
a significant minority in Pakistan some
900,000 members of the ethnic group live
in the country especially in and around
Quetta and they fear for their lives
every day because Sunni extremists
consider the mostly Shiite group
heretics and target them with precision
and regularity 2013 was a particularly
bloody year string of bombings claimed
the lives of some 130 people in January
in February another bomb Bocock attack
killed 110 people and injured many more
the violence continues just last month a
suicide bomber targeted a market
frequented by Hazaras killing 21 the
danger is so serious that cuentas Hazara
community relies on armed protection
24/7 it should be a routine task but
it's a massive security operation these
Hazara men are heading to the city
market to buy and sell food they're
travelling in convoy and are protected
by heavily armed men necessary measures
to prevent attacks by violent militants
at the market security guards keep a
watchful eye but they're not always able
to guarantee safety just in April a
militant blew himself up in a market
just like this one killing at least 20
people and wounding dozens more many of
the victims were Hazara and supposed to
be under military protection the people
here today know that a trip to the
market carries a deadly risk every time
but not going isn't an option
the market is their bread and butter
was they be doing I'm look I gotta come
naked we didn't come here to work the
attacks wouldn't happen but then we
wouldn't be able to run our homes how'd
we feed the children if we don't work
who will give us money and eager for
quitters Hazaras fear has become a part
of life for years they've been living in
heavily guarded and claves surrounded by
checkpoints and hundreds of guards it's
for their safety but Hazara say their
home has become a prison the younger
generation is facing a lot of difficulty
I swear to god there are so many
difficulties for them it's as if they're
living in an enclosed cage the
government in Islamabad has been vocal
about the need to protect the Hazara
people and flush out the militants who
target them military operations are
ongoing and local authorities say much
progress has been made
we have unearthed many networks here we
arrested them eliminated them destroyed
them there were bomb-making factories we
destroyed the heads of their
organizations and we routed out other
members and their whole front line we
stayed within the law and we did what we
could do LS as the April attack shows
militants are still capable of
inflicting carnage on quitters ethnic
minorities for now members of the Hazara
community will have to continue to go
about their daily lives wondering if
they'll return home at the end of the
day joining us now is Omar huarac with
Amnesty International now Omar after the
April attack Prime Minister Imran Khan
visited the Hazara community in Quetta
and said the government was responsible
for their safety but
violence has been going on for years
there and nothing seems to have changed
why well well this is exactly it we
often get government's making these
processes going there to condole with
victims and they actually only go there
because the victims protest that their
treatment however we have seen that the
government's kind of see them as a
community that can be ignored as they
aren't willing to confront their
attackers and so therefore they
capitulate there's a bit of noise and
amiss with the way what we really need
from the partisan government is a
comprehensive strategy on how to protect
that as our community in quite sir and
its nearby areas so it's just a lip
service and you talk about the need for
a comprehensive plan what do you think
are some of the things that the
government can be doing well I mean
first of all it can begin by holding the
perpetrators accountable we have not
seen that we know who the groups are
they came responsibility for these
attacks they've got an established
pattern they've got bases or areas of
operation in around Balochistan so the
first that could be used to hold them
accountable bring them to justice so
that the victims actually get some sense
of closure for their great loss the
second thing is to actually protect the
neighborhood this is not a big area that
we're talking about a significant
security presence would be enough to
ensure that people can go about their
lives really can go to the mosques
freely can worship freely and not see
each day within the Islamic calendar as
yet another day - as another tragedy
where they're having Siddhant their
loved ones into early graves repeatedly
Omar Warrick thank you